you guys welcome to the brave new world
we're living you're gonna watch this
movie and you're gonna wonder how the
heck peter made it because there are so
many high level shots we wanna show you
just what one person can do with the
tools that are out there and we're gonna
teach you all the secrets right here in
this video ai upscale it oh that's a
little spicy dude it's all right spicy
good i like a tip for you yeah
today's a very special day because
peter's movie scooty just dropped he's
working on it for over three years over
three years it's it's a way past two but
you know what it's done now look you're
gonna watch this movie and you're gonna
wonder how the heck peter made it
because it's literally my opinion like
marvel level visual effects i don't know
about that he has a fully animated
character that looks photoreal for the
entire time and everybody that watches
this is going to have questions about
how you did these shots because there
are so many high level shots so this
project was originally going to be my
senior thesis project in college and
then the pandemic hit and then i dropped
out of college and then two years later
so three years total it's finally
finished i was like oh to two or three
hundred vfx shots i can get that done in
a few months no it took much longer than
that but you know what it's finally done
and i'm very happy with it and i'm
pumped to show you guys how i did it we
want to show you just what one person
can do with the tools that are out there
and we're gonna teach you all the
secrets right here in this video
let's get into some secrets so if you're
watching something with a 3d character
in it a cg character here's what it
entails filming on set with an imaginary
thing there you have to get your eye
lines right you have to get your framing
right for something that is literally
not there you can't screw it up then of
course you have to model this thing you
have to texture this thing you have to
rig it where you basically put a fake
skeleton inside of it and like connect
everything so it moves correctly then
you have to light it for each scene that
it's going to be in you have to cut
anything out that's going to be in front
of it by hand then you have to composite
it where you all take all those layers
you put them together you match the
colors you match the gamma and the
contrast so it ideally looks like it
belongs in your shot and you do that
over and over and over it is so much
work so how did you pull it off how did
you make a cg character all by yourself
okay so there were like two or three
hundred vfx shots but towards the end i
found a workflow that made it go pretty
quickly through all of the tools that
have been coming out in the past few
years it's just become so accessible
through motion capture through 3d
scanning sets and things like that so
really utilizing those tools to my
advantage was the only reason i could
have done this
[Music]
so one of the beautiful things about
shooting something without any money or
permits is that you get these beautiful
moments of people being mad at you
so there is a moment where matt is
throwing a scooter on the ground and
water comes from above out of nowhere
and just drops on him and that was
actually someone in real life who was
mad that we were making a lot of noise
and dropped water on us but it was so
funny because matt immediately just
happened to fall after that
i was wondering what that was i felt
like a lightheaded turned on see there's
water that's what people have been
saying so i need to i need to emphasize
that you need a water splash yeah all
right so your robot looks perfectly
photoreal how did you get that step you
know you have a 3d model and dirt does
not exist in cgi if you leave a 3d model
on your hard drive it's not going to
collect dust the more you move it around
it doesn't scratch the edges yeah
exactly
you drag the file across your desktop
and it gets dirtier no so you have to
add that stuff in manually because
that's what makes things look realistic
are the imperfections and so there's
this amazing software called substance
painter where you basically import your
3d model and it does some processing on
it it says okay where are the contours
of this where are the little crevices
that dirt would get into and then you
can use that information to drive
textures there's a tire on scooty that's
filled with a bit of mud in the in the
little crevasses you can also do things
like the little edges of of metal where
there's paint on it but on the edge it
would get scuffed off those little
details at a distance add so much in the
realm of like photo realism yeah i let
you get away with just nice close-up
shots of the head right so the eyebrows
were a big thing originally the model
didn't have any eyebrows and i was
really struggling through the animation
and the voice to really like sell the
emotion of the character how do people
express themselves it's through eyebrows
right you know the rock is great at that
so then i just threw these little
handlebar or or brake pad eyebrows on
there and it helped sell the emotion so
much better because then you could like
bring them down for anger or up for
surprise or like up and slanted for
sadness really helps take the animation
a long way notice also for the the eyes
you'd use the light pattern to like do
like you know eyelids up a little bit or
like eyelids down or like wide-eyed i
did this one lesson a long time ago that
i've never lost it it's always stuck
with me it's just expressions and it's
eyebrows and it's how far down on the
pupil and the iris their top eyelid goes
and how far up your bottom eyelid goes
and the relationship of those three
things is all you need for every human
emotion i got so good at smiling with a
mask during the pandemic it's like even
with this if you just
you know you go like that it's like i'm
smiling you know
i mean you just kind of look insane
now you have to animate it and you just
sit there by hand that'd be impossible
to animate this for that many shots
right i did that for the spider-man uh
short back in the day and that was that
just was hell thankfully we have motion
capture now originally we tried to get
motion capture data on set we had the
actor riley olsen he was wearing a
motion capture suit on set but he
tragically sat down really hard on the
hub of the motion capture suit in a car
and disconnected some of the wires and
so then for the entirety of production
we did not have a functioning motion
capture suit on set so we had to figure
something else out now in these scenes
if you look we actually have riley just
just acting as if he's a human character
in the scene no motion capture suit no
cg no nothing and then we use what's
called rotomation which is they they use
it on spider-man a lot which is where
you look at the actor you're like this
is basically what they did and you match
that in your animation instead but i did
a bit more of like a manual approach to
that where i put on the motion capture
suit and i watched the footage over and
over i was like okay i see you riley and
then i stood up in my motion capture
suit and acted it out the same way and
then we got motion capture that was
pretty similar to what the guy did on
set and when you filmed the guy in set
you would just film again without him
there you didn't paint him out right no
no so we do the classic it's like get
the shot all right run out of the frame
now we get the background so then we can
put the cg over the background so how
about later on we're like you know we're
having dinner time you would do the shot
again without riley this is just empty
shots just with matt by himself yeah so
at a certain point tensions were high we
were stressed out and at that point we
were like okay we'll just put riley in
later on just don't worry let's just
let's just film riley is acting behind
the camera just for voice reference for
matt so this whole party sequence riley
was not in any of these shots we just
had matt acting against nothing and we
just threw the scooty in later on i love
that you have like split color lighting
so it really like embeds the robot in
there yeah that's something i really
remember we were working on anime fidget
spinners back in the day and we had a
shot of mike's finger getting sliced off
and you guys lit it with a strong blue
light coming from the side in just that
little detail that specificity made the
cg look so much better it helps contour
the cg and root it in the scene and so
having different color temperatures of
lights really helps solidify the cg
character in there now i also notice you
have all these shadows in the chair
there so yeah another great use of the
polycam app on the iphone is if i have
an object or a seat that scooty is
interacting with and i need to get the
proper shadows and reflections on that
object then i can just scan it with my
phone throw it in the 3d software and
set it to be what's called a shadow
catcher which is it's an invisible
object that only displays the shadows
that are being cast onto it and so then
when you slap it on top of the original
footage you get the correct shadows that
follow the contour of the object even
though scooty wasn't even in the scene
so i love that you're using accessible
motion capture suits to give emotion and
using accessible 3d scanning tools to
let you scan all the objects in the
scene for catching shadows or scanning
the environment for like getting correct
reflections and light you are knocking
out weeks and weeks of work because this
took three years to make multiple
pieces of software came out in that time
that made all this stuff so much easier
so a shot that would have taken me a few
days at the beginning of the process
would have taken me half a day at the
end of the process it was fantastic take
these these shots in the alleyway for
instance how did you make it look like
it was filmed on the same camera as the
actual shot it's all about lighting and
whenever we were on set i would scan the
set and then you have a near perfect 3d
recreation of the set did you do hdris
also so you can't 3d scan the sky it's
too far away so you 3d scan the set
around you and then you throw in an hdri
which is a high dynamic range image and
so if you drop your cg character into
that it'll light it pretty accurately
and that mixed with the 3d scan of the
set gives you perfect lighting how did
you get your hdris there's a beautiful
website called polyhaven.com hdri and
it's just a community compiled library
of hdris and they have every lighting
condition sunny cloudy sunset and you
find the one that's most accurate to
your scene and just plop it in granted
you lit it the same as your actual shot
but it still looks like it was filmed
with the same camera like it blends how
did you actually do that part so you
have your 3d render and you have your
footage and usually if you just slap
them on top of each other it doesn't
look very good the contrast is going to
be off the shadows and highlights are
going to be different in each shot so
you take your scientific eye and you use
color tools like levels or curves to
match the shadows match the highlights
and match the saturation of each shot
and that's pretty much it on top of that
all cameras have a little bit of blur to
them you match the blur you match the
depth of field and there you go
all right so this is the first time we
ever see scooty he is struck by
lightning why yeah get into the because
he's got to be in the movie
i can't help but notice you have
lighting from the lightning like on the
pole there and there's shadows happening
on the wall so we tried to be good vfx
artists and we brought a big led panel
to the set and we tried to flicker it
you know to make it light up the
environment but it was not bright enough
the day was too bright so i ended up
doing a 3d reconstruction of the scene
to project light from the lightning onto
i just took the raw footage and i threw
it into reality capture which is a 3d
scanning program and then i used that
very rough mesh to then block out the
geometry of the scene using that i could
just cast naturally the light that would
be emitting from the lightning onto the
scenes which goes a long way in selling
the lightning effect i was pretty proud
of the way this
scooter formation scene took shape
because i reversed my animation of
scooty just getting up off of the ground
and then i did a physics simulation of
all the pieces falling off of it and
then you reverse that footage and then
it looks like all the pieces are like
magnetizing to it
all right so we take a look at like this
shot right here where he's up against
the wall traditionally you would film
the background and then you'd have your
cg model and you'd have to composite in
the model over the background but for a
shot like this it's kind of a waste of
time like couldn't you just do a 3d
background like can you just poly cam it
at this point yeah it's like towards the
end there were so many vfx shots and i
had to get like 20 done every day i was
like there's no more time no more time
to composite things ever it's all gonna
be done purely 3d and so i actually
would go back to locations like this one
i just drove over i scanned it i drove
back home i plopped it in and then you
have a perfect cg background to just
drop your model into you don't have to
even composite anything because it's all
just straight out of the renderer we
actually see this happening a lot now in
like marvel films like a lot of stuff
film they at least have the reference
for like it was easy to just replace the
entire thing if you're putting a 3d
object into something that already
exists it's tough to get it to interact
with light in that environment whereas
if you have a purely cg environment all
the shadows and reflections and lighting
are just natural and so you get really
realistic lighting on the background
just from your 3d subject being there in
the first place okay so this is part
where he has a box
nico i don't want to talk about the box
he's holding this server
i'm taking this in for uh
yes i'm watching this i'm like that
looks like a pretty expensive prop that
looks like a big piece of metal that
needs to be laser cut so like looking at
the rest of this film i'm not seeing a
lot of expensive props for locations but
that looks like an expensive prop but it
also looks a little via sexy but he's
holding it i'm like there's no way peter
had him hold something like a copper box
and just vfx in an actual box for this
did he so
let me let me just
show you the raw footage here
oh my god
poor man so this was straight up a green
cardboard box that this guy was carrying
the thing about this cardboard box in
particular is that it was falling apart
it was not a rigid structure and so
sometimes it would be a little bit
longer or a little bit shorter and when
you're 3d tracking something that really
throws things off so i had to hand track
a lot of this box when you say hand
track you mean you just eyeballed it
eyeballing would be if you literally
just like rotate the box into place and
like just put it there and hope it looks
good what i ended up doing was i did a
3d track like a computed 3d track but i
hand tracked all the points for that i
would go through and have like a little
tracker point and i would put it on the
corner of the box i'll go to the next
frame i would drag it to where that
corner of the box was and i did that for
every corner for like however many
frames and then hit compute and it gave
a pretty janky outcome usually and then
it was a lot of tweaking to get it to
look good oh man and he had to deal with
the shadows you have to deal with his
little thingies being all up over it
there are so many liberties taken with
this where there are some places where
it's being squished and stretched in
really unnatural ways if you look
closely yeah this shot you can see in
the beginning of this
it does go from shot long air
conditioner style to like more of a box
that's literally because the box was
falling apart part of it was like
sagging
so the guy who made this prop did a
great job but we just used it so much
that it ended up falling apart so i also
noticed that you know the robot's just
in a lot of footage you filmed like how
did you motion track all of it you mean
as opposed to like having a static
background yeah supposed like a locked
off camera or you know a fully 3d scene
it's a mixture of a few different
techniques we have the after effects
automatic camera tracker which is just a
godsend you basically just feed it your
footage hit analyze and it spits out a
perfect 3d camera that then you can
bring into your scene and you plop your
model in and it just sticks another one
is the blender camera tracker which is
built in it's a bit more manual but it's
better for the tougher shots where after
effects can't quite understand it so
yeah it was pretty straightforward that
was honestly one of the easiest parts
was camera tracking all those shots
come on i got places to be
so these shots the of scooty in the car
100 cg car 100 cg car real background so
you just got a shot looking out the
window or something while you drove down
the street exactly i bought a 30
like suction mounted camera rig and i
just put my dslr on it and drove down
that street in san francisco and old
fashioned rear projection style in the
shot so like this shot here like this
camera motion happening like it's
framing up are you actually just taking
your background shot and then just
cropping into an area and then back out
so i'm using the ian hubert method where
you have your footage in your 3d scene
so then you can take another camera and
kind of do your own camera move even
though you already filmed the footage
with a different camera that's how i did
clock blockers if you 3d track your
camera you take the 3d tracked camera
and you project the footage from the
camera it's as if you're just creating a
window into reality again and now you
have a stabilized window the perfect way
of explaining it so yeah i use that a
ton on this a lot of the footage of uh
jake blading down the hills in san
francisco was that we had footage of him
on a green screen and we 3d tracked that
and then put the cg background in there
and then could animate a camera
independently of the original camera so
how about this that's gotta be a 3d
background right there now yeah that
this shot is 100 3d that's all kit bash
3d skyscrapers so this is all 3d too
that looks like it's a real shot thanks
yeah i'm really happy with that one i
think the fabric moving and the hair
moving helps sell it a lot
about the background here so this is a
giant large-scale satellite 3d model of
san francisco that i got from
3dcadbrowser.com threw it in there it's
done it was amazing
the shot of uh jake holding onto the
airplane i'm so proud of this is he i'm
guessing he's just lying on the ground
yep
wait a minute those are cg legs and
torso you cut them off at the shoulder i
cut them off at the shoulders wow so we
very strategically placed matt in his
clothing on set so that we could cut
just around his shoulder and replace his
second half the legs are hand animated i
could have made them look more realistic
but i just thought it was so funny how
floppy and like all over the place they
were so i kind of hammed it up a bit i
can't help but notice that you're
dropping the exposure a little bit it
looks like where the hair is motion
blurring you know what i think i'm using
andrew kramer's motion blur technique
andrew kramer king of vfx came into the
studio and let ren in on a little secret
for motion blur to make it look way more
accurate normally cg motion blur at
least in after effects or things like
that is just perfectly blurred out
whereas in real life it has a little bit
more shape to it it's a little bit more
full so in after effects you put on uh
you change your color space to 32-bit
and you put on an exposure uh effect to
turn the exposure all the way down then
you calculate your motion blur and then
you put an exposure effect turning all
the way back up and then for some reason
it just magically looks way better
i don't know why it's like it's like an
nd filter basically it changes the
exposure what's behind it right exactly
and so i don't know if it was like the
bit depth in my camera that i was
shooting at or something like that but i
tried to key these shots using blue
screen techniques and it just was not
working very well it looked all chunky
in the hair it looked like bad blue
screen hair so i ended up using after
effects as rota brush tool which is
basically just an ai assisted
rotoscoping tool where it helps you cut
out something over a long period of
frames and it has this amazing edge
refined feature where you basically just
like click over the hair and it's like
all right i got you and it just like
makes it look amazing it's really nice
actually it's like one of the features
that after effects has it's legit really
good everything needs that soft refined
tool yeah so this shot right here
3d model no that's a shutterstock drone
okay shutterstock has so much of my
money topaz labs was so amazing for this
project you know you can buy stock
footage at like 4k and it's like 300
or you can buy stock footage at like
720p and it's like 50 bucks but then you
just use topaz labs to ai up scale it
that's a little spicy
good i like a tip for you guys welcome
to the brave new world we live in
mikko how's it how's your head feeling
my head's feeling great because i feel
inspired i feel like i can go out and
shoot a movie and do all the effects
honestly you do some incredible work
here and if you haven't watched the
video yet you have no idea what i'm
talking about go to the channel corridor
it's where we put all our short films
including scooty yes this has been a lot
of fun going through this with you i'm
super hyped with how this movie turned
out and i'm excited for everybody to see
it so go watch it if you haven't and uh
yeah enjoy
validate me validate me i want it and
push my ego to the stars let's go let's
go i'm ready to blast off let's go